pour le président brésilien l'épidémie
de kobe 19 ne serait qu'une petite
grippe
pourtant les derniers chiffres ont de
quoi inquiéter les autorités
aujourd'hui plus de 250 mille personnes
ont contracté le virus
presque dix sept mille en sont mortes
malgré une situation de plus en plus
alarmante gerbe also know continue de
critiquer les mesures de confinement
prise par certains gouverneurs du pays
le chômage la faim et la misère seront
l'avenir de ceux qui soutiennent la
tyrannie de l' isolement total
déclaration du président brésilien
seulement deux jours après la démission
de son ministre de la santé
le deuxième en moins d'un mois à ce
poste toujours sur fond de désaccords
liés à la crise du coronavirus
aujourd'hui les voix contre les choix
stratégiques de bolton arrow se font
entendre
à commencer par celle d'un ancien chef
d'état comme je suis catholique
un homme qui croit en dieu je continue
de prier pour que le peuple brésilien
échappent à ce génocide
d'irresponsabilité causés par bolton
araud a mon avis bolson araud a commis
plusieurs crimes
il a attaqué la démocratie il a attaqué
les institutions il a attaqué le peuple
brésilien car il n'a aucun respect pour
les personnes qui sont décédées
il n'a aucun respect pour les personnes
qui sont contaminées ici au brésil déjà
dramatique la situation pourrait encore
s'aggraver au brésil d'après les experts
le pic de l'épidémie n'interviendra
qu'au mois de juin même si les soutiens
du président en place sont nombreux à
chacune de ses apparitions publiques
elle ses détracteurs le sont tout autant
un climat de tension donc qui pourrait
se transformer à l'avenir en véritable
crise politique